hi guys I'm Greg I've been very busy
working a couple of things that I
mentioned the Deadpool 2 trailer review
specifics are there go to there and
that's how youtubers promote other
videos what I'm going to watch the day
was the trailer that came out very
recently called geo storm
Nordia storm fell the Geo storm Marko
Tonetta herro he's the one to request
this he said it's a great trailer I'll
tell you if it's great I see plenty of
trailers I know things the Geo storm
right there technology that control
[Music]
hover whoa yeah feels like that damn
Andy Garcia drug Butler to do for Meet
the Fockers
whoa whoa whoa
Wow
crazy the world's freezing over that's
what a geo storm is okay are we sure
roland emmerich did not direct this film
because it would say that on the trailer
he did not a couple of guys have done a
lot of television have directed this
okay looks a lot like a role in Emmerich
so what does it look like the day after
you just named a roland emmerich film
about disaster around the world that
looks like that
although here's what I'll give it here
it'll say whenever I see one of those
Roland Emmerich trailers it just looks
like flashy visual effects and while
there's a good amount of that going on
in here a teaser trailers can sometimes
be darker than the actual films Justino
reel you in and all that however the way
it's shot the way everything looks and
when the tone is communicating from the
trailer it looks like actually a little
scary look at dark you know it's the one
weird thing about those Roland Emmerich
films they're like fun disaster flicks
or even like san andreas for example and
while this is definitely going to go in
a territory of like ridiculousness it
feels rather dark it feels like things
are actually going to hit you or hit
these characters it specifically kicked
in at that moment before you see Anne
Harris
yeah when around like fifty-one seconds
when those law enforcement people are
walking through the snow and there's a
guy frozen there and you know that's the
idea of this world freezing over like
with the plane sort of like it in at a
tornado where they're just crashing down
or thunder hits them or something
there was a trippy and a different way
to show us a plane falling from the sky
where it's frozen and it's just going
down flat that is the kind of moment
that scared me I would like it if this
felt like a horror film you know like it
halfway through the trailer like or will
have a lot of strays communicating that
it feels a little bit like a horror
flick the Roland Emmerich films the
disaster film don't really feel scary
they feel more like an action film same
thing with San Andreas this seems to be
trying to add actual suspense and horror
like elements to the world of a disaster
movie some concern too
our Butler doesn't usually make good
movies Andy Garcia
but then again going with like how this
trailers going for the more like Oh make
it feel scary
I feel like roland emmerich teaser
trailers 2.2 you know they could have
like 2012 or the day after tomorrow or
this even kind of feels like into the
storm definitely got that san andreas
live in there you got a lot of that
going on there but the way it's
specifically shot and captured and just
a few of those glimpses what's weird is
I feel like in a lot of these disaster
films you don't really see too many dead
bodies so there was something rather
eerie about seeing a frozen man like the
way that shot was done and all the
police unit are all going around and
like that was those was a real as a shot
that really stood out to me actually it
I was a part room like maybe Oh watches
and then again a lot of the effects
though who's the greatest not granted to
you know I don't want to criticize the
film too much for its visual effects
because this is you know still in
post-production I'm sure and some of the
times it looks like great effects for
the 90's or some great sci-fi general
effects but sometimes it does look
really good and keep in mind too when I
say darker I'm not saying more realistic
it just looks darker and hooray for more
creepy covers of old songs being in
another trailer that that's not getting
old alright if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe at the real rejects
follow me at the greg alba on instagram
and twitter and shout out to john our
book lover whatever I took I took to the
side of my face I can't really do an
American exit your honor
oh we have my law abiding citizen this
is the ugly truth I can't deal good
Gerard Butler but he can't do an
American accent